[Music]
in wild weather news Oh like snow like
hurricanes Nikki like I bet you it's
about mr. harvey submitted by step love
JK Thank You Steph hurricane Steve
Harvey has devastated the Gulf Coast how
come it's not a Mexican name thank you
because it's coming from Mexico why
can't it be a black name I guess there's
a black name right I know I heard
actually heard somebody [ __ ] about that
a couple years ago so like how come
traditional lines are not used for her
team we need to be represented in
hurricanes everybody is there a reason
why a lot of hurricanes are usually
names of Hispanic people or is that
something else
there was a reason for why certain
hurricanes were named I think in in the
States
I forgot what it was or no tornadoes I'm
sorry I don't know what the reason for
the name hurricane or like this natural
disaster disaster or some [ __ ] there's a
reason for it they talked about it
before but I think brands should be able
to pay states to do to have the name of
the kur king yeah hurricane Chevron and
then then we get the money really good
marketing I would like it they would
talk about all day exact a and JK C is
taking the city by has ravaged the
country or even like to say these Disney
wants to do it because the storm is
coming as a hurricane Star Wars the last
that's [ __ ] brand hurricane Jafar all
the evil bill in it should make a theme
of fictional characters for the
hurricane names instead of actual people
names like hurricane magneto other
people that are having kids during these
natural disasters and then they name
their kids after that
that's awful being born I saw a meme of
there's these two dogs humping in them
why do you watch all these animals
having sex really she was like I watched
two turtles having sex because he's not
not to watch porn anymore you know it's
cuz he watched so much porn it's the
only [ __ ] that gets them off yeah
because I follow weird in students they
always have these funny memes of funny
videos and has to do with like sexual
[ __ ] but anyways there was this
Instagram meme it was 2000 during the
hurricane it says before I drown imma
drown this [ __ ] yes as you guys have
heard hurricane Harvey okay I know it's
me I can't be seared can't be laughing
it's tough man it's tough for me
honestly that's what comedies for is to
make make light of really dark things so
no no no this is making fun of anybody
on hurricane or the hurricane victims
it's just a way to be like [ __ ] the
world's like sucks right now
yeah Kevin Harvick's pork challenge
where he was like calling out people as
I hey man I'm giving 25,000 so I'm gonna
call out my brothers Ludacris t I if I
was one of his personal friends I'd be
like oh [ __ ] your ass up oh yeah Master
P got pissed he said the same thing he's
like why are you calling out these
people let them get what they want to go
yeah it's like Parker's Master P's like
I can't slice up you know how long I was
relevant you think you call it Jerry
Seinfeld yeah I'm like out of all those
people in my group Jerry
stands out anyways it's like it's bread
yeah so this is the first time in 56
years that a major hurricane made
landfall in Texas it's hit Corpus
Christi which is actually where you're
from Port Aransas yeah right how was
your family dealing with everything so I
have my I actually went to Puerto Rico I
went to college in Corpus Christi and
this is right where the hurricane hit so
I've got a lot of family there a lot of
friends there but luckily no one I know
is hurt but they drove away we are the
only evacuated but my uncle's house
where my little cousins live and there
they watch so shout-out to you guys I
love you their house got ravaged so like
your shingles fell off the roof like in
there in those you know beach towns they
have the houses on the stilts or yeah
their house is still [ __ ] up like the
shingles fell off the roof caved in like
they can't live there now they have to
get their living in a like a FEMA
sponsored apartment now like and they
have to go to school in the next town so
it's like they're I mean it's just weird
like to think like how could you make
your kids go to school during the storm
all of these like kids you don't need an
education right now my grandpa would
have made this good could go to school
during the swamp oh yeah he's like we
had the Great Depression so you get your
ass out in the hurricane
yeah these hurricanes go away my hunger
barely did I like those boats those
swamp boat yeah skip of through the time
she went to the front door Jesus yeah
they're saying that they've gotten a
entire year's worth of rain within like
five days and it took about 20 trillion
gallons of water which is enough to fill
the states of California Alaska like an
entire state you can hover that whole
state with one inch of water which is
how much they fund and Louisiana is also
being affected as well
Louisiana always getting flooded
Houston is it's a beautiful leg so
messed up though I mean they see these
are probably all in Houston because
Houston got it the worst scene even that
she like right there that's so dangerous
right there
these guys are risking their lives out
there it's not just they're driving in
that because they don't know where the
sinkholes are oh yeah where the road is
even that's the ballsy [ __ ] that should
happen on the release of [ __ ] you know
the releasing of [ __ ] and then people
are like we're gonna still trying to
watch it hey you were showing in Houston
yeah and then one of our first do they
like Peters throwing up we're not
leaving do it one of our first [ __ ]
suppose that his friend actually went to
it and he sent him a picture
[Laughter]
that's funny wait the city was still
operating during the hurricane I know
there's no showing movies he was it was
dirty it was the Friday so I guess was
like the day before it was when the
warning happened did Houston evacuate
too no really
is that a cow horses or cows that's a
cow Lassen I know it Kelly you've been
watching a lot of cow bucking yeah I
watch a lot Calvin I know what can I say
so Houston didn't evacuate now so like I
think well I know Porter ANZUS which is
the city I grew up and they had an
evacuation they had a mandatory
evacuation but I think Houston is so big
and then there's something that governor
was saying like it could even cause more
problems trying to get that many people
out at once because you know those
highways are gonna be drawn fact like
yeah so I think they were kind of taking
a chance yeah because there's always
hurricanes that common tree like oh it's
gonna be a big one oh nothing happened
why are they taking cars instead of
boats like well they take rafts and
stuff maybe they don't have enough boat
how would you get a piece of wood
there's a I'll just get a mattress dude
I would yeah so it's crazy so this one's
got a bee or a cockroach this time viral
and what this is it's fire ants forming
like their own little boat so this is on
themselves to protect the Queen prolly
yeah so apparently the entire colony is
here I would not want to jump in that
and apparently this is really common
during floods it supposedly fire-ants
always do this where they just float
there and they're saying that as soon as
they touch any sort of object they're
immediately who they want to get out of
the water so if you accidentally run
into that I'm diving I'm [ __ ] diving
in that's like an Indiana Jones movie
dude
yes let me show you watch that [ __ ]
what's this [ __ ] floats right into your
house and now your whole house is just
cold so they say that if you do ever
come across like a thing of fire ants to
just move the water to create ripples to
move it away from you but don't touch it
don't just [ __ ] don't use like a
stick don't use anything I love this if
you come across a pool together thing of
ten thousand fires or 10 million as you
do I would be a viral video so fast cuz
you'll see like I kid you not like a
bunch of like animal activists but that
is beautiful and then you see me with a
can you have to get close enough to
spray it out what the wasp [ __ ] I had
that [ __ ] she was like a cannon yeah and
also by the way there's not allowed
please around like you could [ __ ]
light a bow and arrow on fire some of
that [ __ ] get tribal on their ass celtic
[ __ ] burial ritual
I'll take those [ __ ] out a
little gasoline than one lighter done
well that's what I'm saying like it's
like it was kind of crazy like he called
out all these people and I'm saying it
personally
or even companies themselves so there
have been already two dates about 42
corporations I have donated a million
each and Verizon themselves they've
donated ten million note thank you for I
know it's like big ups a [ __ ] ton of
people just see that's why they outfit
brezin has the highest prices so they
could donate so tell me Kevin Hart the
most popular commune in the world did
25k I think he went up to 50 but he was
dude Sandra Bullock dumped a million on
yeah that's like
now she should call his ass out yeah oh
yeah what's up I'm Sandra Bullock um you
know I haven't done anything in like a
couple years and I just dumped a million
on this [ __ ] keV are so yeah just caught
one guy Kevin oh yeah yeah she lives in
Texas so I guess that's why she got more
inclined to give more but but yeah like
as time has progressed there's been more
and more celebrities and more companies
donating and with each each announcement
it's like the number goes higher are you
trying to like one-up each other yeah
like that's what's happening which is
good good that's a good that's a good
thing you know back in 2005 Katrina
brought in 1 billion dollars in
donations over the course of 6 months
yeah and where did all the money go I
don't think it was enough right like
even a billion dollars wasn't enough to
fix that it was just like so devastating
yeah dude as as a Texan myself because I
was conceived moved to Virginia no to
Indiana but I am of course you're either
a redneck hillbilly which I'm a Texan
okay I just feel so what's your football
team was it what's your football team
[Laughter]
Texas Cowboys your Texans oh you know
I've never died and where each of those
jerseys how about that hey excuse me I
am a native Texan also no you're not I
was made there no you what do you call
that your [ __ ] zygote was made there
you weren't made there my hell was I go
hey you married my ziege I would never
marry yours I never [ __ ] use this
video Oh cold I'm cold man
Mindy Nash it's from Indianapolis where
I was technically born but always felt a
special connection to Texas because of
and Virginia depending on what time of
day you talk to him
I grew up there where'd you spend the
most of your childhood in California oh
but he'll never claim it San Diego no
why because it was so full of
Quicksilver douche bags Elsa Coughlin
I don't know where else to call hey you
guys want to stock any of us we'll go
ahead down to the description box below
and you can follow us on Instagram and
all kinds of stuff for more videos
[Music]